um but welcome back for now to
protesters from just stop oil who spent
11 days demonstrating in London blocking
roads throwing painted shops and
restaurants today a fire engine and an
ambulance were briefly caught up in
their blockade prompting the British
government to save this kind of protest
isn't acceptable what Jenny Cleveland's
still with me I'm joined by to talk to
the contributor Richard ties and from
just stop oil a James key Mrs key
welcome thank you very much for coming
in appreciate it at what point when
you're blocking fire engines and
ambulances are you concerned about lives
being cost lost by what you're doing
well the whole reason we're doing this
is because we're concerned about the
lives you get the irony that if you're
actually stopping ambulances and fire
engines is going to save people's lives
they may actually die because of your
protest well actually we have a blue
light policy we're let through every
emergency vehicle you didn't know and if
you actually cared to run the whole
footage there you'd see that that
ambulance um is advised by one of our
people uh to avoid the roadblock and
what is the sensible thing or just get
out of the way you have no right
absolutely no right to obstruct other
people's daily lives you have the right
to protest on the side of the street you
are unlawfully in the middle of the
street it's utterly outrageous it's
selfish and you are putting people's
lives at risk I I appreciate your
frustration and I understand that I
empathize with that but look we are
demanding that the the government hold
any new licensing and consents any
fossil fuel exploration in the UK now
you know that that needs to happen I
know it doesn't need to happen it does
need to happen
if we need to ensure millions of people
living on this planet the United Nations
because of cheap energy from fossil
fuels you can't get cheaper than free
all right okay Renewables are nine times
cheaper than it was not free we spend 15
billion subsidizing Renewables
we spend 236 million pounds a week
sorry James what you're saying is alive
just to bring you back is actually my
show and I'm doing the interview
although happily talking
and by the way he's not frustrated he's
Furious right my question remains though
with you where is your moral line with
this you say you want to save lives and
yet your actions are bordering on
potentially costing lives you cannot get
in the way of Emergency Services in the
way that you're doing and if you do want
to explain the moral difference between
what you're doing and what you complain
everyone's doing about the planet
well I mean let's look if we want to
talk about disruption and earlier
the fire brigade the lunar fire brigade
had their busiest day since the blitz
okay 60 UK families lost their houses
and wildfires why are we not talking
about them why are we concentrating on
such a small bit of Destruction
disruption is nothing in comparison to
what's coming here and you know it you
know it you think it's small I say to
you you have no idea the damage you're
doing when you get in the way of
Emergency Services my question is why is
no emergency why are the lives of the
people who you're putting at risk by
stopping those fire engines why are you
why are you manipulating your audience
Miss framing what is my question why are
the lives of the people who whose lives
may be affected by your actions today
why are they less important to you than
the lives that you say will be cost by
not taking climate change more seriously
I value everyone's life
absolutely stop lying
I for the record I agree with you I
think it's ridiculous it's down to
nurses doctors bartenders whatnot to be
going out in the street and demanding
what the government should just be doing
anyway right this is this is
because it wouldn't work wait wait wait
wait okay yeah I think and and I don't
want to speak for you James but I think
a lot of these campaigns have to do with
it's a numbers game but there may be a
small number of people inconvenienced uh
today but they are looking at an
existential threat way into the future
which will involved many many right now
many many more people and the fact is
this protest is incredibly effective
because here we are we're talking about
it
listen I'm happy to have James arms
caring passionately about causes right
I'm not saying I'm against your cause
I'm really getting against your
methodology doesn't it I don't think it
does open history book I don't think it
suffrages it doesn't work highly
disrupted Civil Rights Movement highly
disruptive gay rights highly disruptive
you know it works you're a journalist
you
I don't think it works when you're lying
in front of Emergency Services I don't I
don't you will lose the British public
and my concern for you guys you keep
thinking any disruption is valid and any
disruption works and I'm saying to you
yes you're on this show but you're on
this show because people are absolutely
Furious yeah you got in the way of
ambulances and fire engines and I say
you can do both gone you you can make
vociferous protests but you don't have
to get in the way of things that are
saving people's lives why don't you tell
your audience about the the actual
disruption that's coming on Down the
Line why don't you bring qualified
climate scientists on here to explain
what civilizational collapse looks like
all right we've lost a third of our
wheat yields this year we're projected
to lose 50 of our potato Harvest if it's
this bad in 2022 how bad is it going to
be in 2050 you know if we have food
shortages that leads to
civilization collapse I'm sorry I'm
sorry
you're objectively
you are lying are you
the dogmatic nature as I have learned
myself screaming at the other side
rarely has the effect you think it does
it makes you feel better and I've done
it with you know people on various
debates it never actually works you
don't you don't change anyone's Mind by
screaming but I think future Generations
will probably look back in shock and
horror at our ability to turn away from
something I don't necessarily think that
you will be winning over a lot of people
that don't already agree with your cause
with this you will be getting your
message
are you going to continue
stopping Emergency Services going about
it will continue until the government
makes a meaningful separation of any new
license